we all have a friend with a crazy habit
for me it's my best friend Paul whom
I've known for 21 years Paul has
difficulties throwing stuff away his
house is filled with boxes
floor-to-ceiling hundreds of boxes
there's so much stuff on his kitchen
floor that you can't even tell what
color the florists whole waste a lot of
time in his life looking for stuff he
needs he frequently hurts himself
walking around the house and tripping on
something sharp pulse habit is also
holding him back he had to turn down a
job offer because with all this stuff at
his house he simply couldn't move to
another city I'm sure we all agree that
Paul has a problem in the real world
this problem is called hoarding fine in
the virtual world you and I are no
different than Paul we desperately hold
on to every bit of data we download or
generate letting it clutter on lights
wasting our time and holding us back
when was the last time you cleaned up
this desktop or your documents folder
when was the last time we went through
our photos on the phone and deleted the
eighty percent of photos we don't care
about so that we can more easily find
the ten that we do I'm sure you all say
that it's different out there in the
digital world it's a different type of
hoarding after all all this data doesn't
really cause you any pain well it's a
problem and I believe that together we
can deal with it true data is small but
there's just so much of it and it's
growing at an unprecedented pace this
represents the total amount of data that
mankind generate it
until the year nineteen eighty it's
equivalent to about four billion
Encyclopedia Britannica and this
represents the amount of data that
mankind generate it yesterday in 24
hours if we don't change our habits will
be overwhelmed with data all this
digital mess is weighing us down and we
don't even realize the sheer amount of
time that we are our computers spent
going through data is shocking we waste
an estimated twenty-five hours each year
going through data we don't need waiting
for computers to index the data that we
don't need 25 hours that's more than one
full day that we could be spending with
our friends or their family deepening
our personal relationships with others
instead of staring at the computer
screen businesses are particularly
susceptible to this problem the
notorious for keeping data around they
don't delete anything they don't clean
anything up and there's a price for that
it costs them an estimated twelve
hundred dollars per employee per year in
time wasted and storage costs and when
it comes to reviewing files for legal
purposes businesses ways tens of
thousands of dollars having their
lawyers go through garbage but it's not
just about the time that we waste not
being able to find stuff it's very
difficult and very hard for us when you
actually need to find something
important I know this firsthand you see
I'm the recovering data folder
I used to store every single fire I ever
received and I never really cared about
where to put it why should I develop my
mental mental efforts to organizing my
data to cleaning my data well my habit
came to bite me once I was trying to
secure a lease for my dream New York
City apartment the landlord asked me for
a letter of reference from a previous
employer well I didn't have a printed
version but since I've saved every
single file have received it should be
pretty easy to find it on my computer so
I started looking for it but then as I
kept looking I realized that I had no
idea where I put it and in retrospect it
was pretty important so I searched
through literally thousands of files my
college essays the grocery lists and
other useless files I found the document
15 minutes later but it was too late the
landlord had already given the apartment
to someone else someone more organized
had I realized how much clutter I was
surrounding myself with and been able to
do something about it I would have
enjoyed my dream apartment in New York
City one with the washer and dryer in
the unit a washer and dryer
it's a big deal in your city holding on
to our data also changes the way we
behave were much less spontaneous
because we keep surrounding ourselves
with the record of the past life has
taught me that lesson I was planning a
trip to the northeast to see all my
friends I was excited to go through all
the emails and notes and photos to make
a list of everyone I'm going to see to
remember all the conversations we didn't
finish so I could finish those
conversations and then my hard drive
crash unable to make a precise plan I
had no choice but to be spontaneous
silent chance decide who to see instead
of rehashing old conversations I started
new ones instead of talking about stuff
from the past we are not talking about
our aspirations I connected with my
friends much more deeply than I had ever
before a few years back Paul decided to
seek help he was tired of being held
hostage by his stuff he couldn't quite
throw anything away but he moved it far
away in storage very far away from him
it helped now you can tell what color
the kitchen Flores and yes Paul moved to
different city and took his dream job
inspired by Paul I no longer hard bits I
keep the important information close
everything else far away that way I have
more time to do the things that I want
to do I can always find something
important and I feel like a much more
spontaneous in life because I'm not
surrounded by the mementos from my past
you too can stop being weighed down by
your data and I'm here to help you with
the first step no I'm not going to ask
you to delete your precious facebook
photos and documents from 10 years ago
my advice is simple organize your life
separate the important from the
unimportant keep the important lean and
organized
close by put the unimportant far away on
an external drive or online that way if
you ever need to access it you can but
you're not going to be reminded by it
every day and I'm going to be distracted
by your data every day we're all data
for ders but if we change our mindsets
just a little if we employ some basic
data hygiene this is not my apartment is
the stock photo we'll have more time to
spend with our friends and our families
and will be more spontaneous we'll be
able to do things we haven't done before
we'll be able to live in the moment and
we'll be able to make much deeper
connections with people and this advice
unlike the clutter it's really worth
keeping thank you